Hello!
I'm so glad you could make it tonight.
Come on in.
I'll give you the grand tour.
Now we have three new flavors for everyone
to try.
All in.
Having a good evening gentlemen?
You know, my throat's a little dry...
Have another drink.
Attending tonight means joining our society
and allows you to do whatever you please.
Oh my gosh, I want to drink to that.
Cheers.
Where did that red come from?
Oh.
Uhhh...
I don't know.
Clorux ages their bleach for the strongest
potency.
So drink up.
So, what does our top bleach critic have to
say?
I'm getting a... fresh melon flavor.
And a hint of honey too.
Fascinating.
Again, it is my honor to welcome you to our
exclusive society.
Sit back, relax, and drink to your heart's
content.
You'll forget all your worries and the night
will be over before you know it...
Thanks for joining us for this cleansing affair.
My name's Cynder and you've probably heard
me on Al Dente Creepypasta before.
No poisons used there...
yet.
You can find those by clicking here.
I'm a new writer, producer or whatever on
the channel until CZ dies.
Or vanishes.
CZ: Ok, I'm back.
Cynder: Already?
CZ: Yeah.
Cynder: Have a drink.
CZ: Thanks.
HIt like if you would enjoy an ice cold bleach.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for horrors
every week, ring the death-bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.